I don't know what version of the story
you got let's start then
hey everyone I'm Ryan Johnson and I'm
here sharing some of my favorite behind
the scenes moments from my new show
Poker Face
one of my favorite scenes in the whole
series Adrian Brody's character Sterling
Jr first invites Charlie into his office
hello Miss kale
I'm happy to finally meet you
Sterling Jr tells the story as he heard
it of the discovery of her gift Once
Upon a Time in Denver
milk toast collection of the best poker
players in central Colorado met at a
Fairfield in Swede off I-25 a young
woman from out of town was at the table
three hours later she mopped the floor
with each and every one of them it was
one of those magical days on set where
just we kind of worked it out like we
were working at a stage play We settled
down in these two great actors get to go
Toe to Toe and to hear you tell the
story I was a Cincinnati Kid
methodically fleecing my way across the
country until my master plan was
thwarted
dude I had no grand plan it's also the
scene where Charlie kind of gives her
definition of who she is she's you know
basically a dumbass is doing just fine
I'm doing just fine I love the way that
both Adrian and Natasha play this scene
holding an ace of spades
[Music]
you're not reading the cards how can I
read the cards for reading me seeing
these two actors dig into it and make it
work I was like ah I think this show
might work you've been graced with a
gift in episode three we had had in the
room the idea of a dog being the reason
that Charlie gets involved in solving a
crime avenge you I don't even like you I
love this idea didn't love the idea of
pulling that emotional rug out from the
audience of introducing a cute adorable
wonderful little puppy and then killing
it I kept wrestling with it and then one
morning in the shower I just like my
eyes popped up and I said what if the
dog's an [__] go on disburse
ice God bless him barked his little
heart out with some help from our sound
department and our great director of
that episode Ian McDonald we managed to
make the most adorable dog in the world
look like a total dick
oh now you want to get out
very good he never reforms his ways but
at least he's happy and healthy no ices
were harmed in the making of this
episode
[Music]
foreign